القوات الاوكرانيه تواصل مساعيها للتقدم
في بعض المناطق شرق البلاد وتتكبد خسائر
لكن الحديث عن تاثير الهجوم المضاد لا
يزال مبكرا للغايه قوه كياف المسلحه
باسلحه غربيه وفي بحثها عن نقاط ضعف في
الخطوط الروسيه كسبت بعض البلدات وخسرت
بعض الاسلحه الغربيه والدبابات منها
تحديدا روسيا اعلنت عن تدمير دببتين صنع
واربعا من ناقلات عن تدمير اربع من ناقلات
الجند الامريكيه من طراز برادلي كما تم
التخلي عن مركبات مدرعه اخرى امريكيه
وفرنسيه خبراء عسكريون ارجعوا عدم تحقيق
اوكرانيا مكاسب كبيره للاستعدادات الروسيه
منذ اشهر للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني وايضا
لاستخدام اوكرانيا عددا صغيرا من القوات
فقط خطوط الدفاع الروسيه صممت لايقاف
الاوكرانيين لاطول فتره ممكنه حتى تتمكن
موسكو من تعزيز دفاعاتها بشكل اكبر وهنا
يقع على القوات الاوكرانيه المتقدمه يقع
عبء اختراق شبكه معقده من الدفاعات
الروسيه التي تمتد مئات الكيلومترات في
شرق اوكرانيا على خطوط التماس في مناطق
السيطره الروسيه الدفاعات الروسيه وفقا
لضابط استخبارات اوكراني تتكون من ثلاثه
خطوط وبمستويات متفاوته من التحصينات التي
يمكن ان يتجاوز عرضها في بعض المناطق 30
كيلومترا كجزء من التحصينات الروسيه بحسب
اكياف او جزء من هذه التحصينات الروسيه
بحسب كاف يتكون من خنادق بعمق اربعه امتار
وعرض سته امتار مضاده للدبابات مع وجود
العوائق الكونكريتيه اضافه للاسلاك
الشائكه والالغام التي ربما تمتد عبر خط
المواجهه باكمله من شبه جزيره القرم وحتى
كامل مساحه الشرق الاوكرانيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات